what's your buddy count
so for me you know it's very much you
know it goes back to that old adage
quality not quantity okay you don't want
to say what number
[Music]
what's your name uh my name is chris
okay yeah nice to meet you so uh can you
tell me a little bit about yourself yeah
of course yeah yeah i am i'm a master's
public health student here in london oh
really
i just moved here in september so i've
only been here for a couple years oh
okay wait so where'd you move from from
amsterdam so have you ever been arrested
no i've never been arrested i'm
definitely i would say like a good girl
i'm really like when i was younger even
and going out drinking you know i was
always the one who's like afraid of
getting into trouble and if my friends
would like do something crazy i would be
the one like no no we can't do that so
no i've never been arrested and i don't
plan to that's brilliant that's pretty
obviously you know you just got to get
those background checks in you know
just in gays yeah i know yeah i mean
i've never been asked this on a date but
it's probably a good question to ask
definitely definitely i mean you get to
learn a lot about a person as well how
do you feel about a prenup
how do i feel about prenup
um
to be honest to be honest
i don't mind it i mean i think it's
there as a level of protection yeah i
mean i think nowadays what's the stat
like it's quite heavy stuff right 50 and
it's in the past exactly yeah and so you
know having a having a prenup doesn't
mean that you necessarily don't love
someone it's literally there as a safety
net i completely agree i i think i
wouldn't get married without a prenup in
my opinion um i think especially if
you're bringing in maybe like more money
into the relationship i think it's
pretty important and it doesn't mean
like you said it doesn't mean that you
expect the relationship to end but you
have to at the end of the day protect
yourself because
i don't know how to say this in a nice
way i think my parents have
um are relatively wealthy and i think
they just would think it's important
that not someone is marrying you for
those reasons or if you were to divorce
that
that your partner wouldn't have a right
to their wealth like i want to make my
own money i want to you know enjoy my
own money but still like i'm entitled to
that money but that doesn't mean that my
partner would be what's your body count
um my body count is eight
i don't know
that's a lot
um what's your body count
so for me you know it's very much it
goes back to that old adage
quality not quantity okay so i'm very
much you know i haven't i haven't got
major major numbers like i know like
like a lot of blokes there sometimes
i've got like 30 to 100 maybe maybe 300
some people like they write it down it's
not for me you know it's it's very much
i really only do that if i'm if i'm
really sort of in the committed
relationship really so it's very very
low numbers
you don't want to say what number
well it's single digits it's single
digits yeah
okay
[Laughter]
i'll probably say
five
yeah
when did you lose your question
uh
um
i mean like does it change your opinion
like if i would have said 20 would that
have changed your opinion or like 30.
um i mean
i know it shouldn't be the case it
shouldn't it probably wouldn't probably
okay like you know it's just something
nice to know you know if you're getting
into a relationship it's always good to
know the background background sort of
thing oh yeah i mean i think it's nice
to know but i don't i have never asked
the guy i've dated how many people
they've slept with i think it's
completely irrelevant yeah yeah
definitely definitely
but it's definitely something that i get
asked a lot so i think it's funny that
like to me it wouldn't matter but to i
think a lot of guys it does
does your perception of a girl change if
she would sleep with you on the first
date
so for me no no it wouldn't it wouldn't
change um because uh i mean obviously if
they if they fancy me then you can't we
can't blame them you know you know what
i mean um so
so yeah i would it wouldn't it wouldn't
uh it wouldn't change
what's your worst quality
well okay that's a that's another spicy
question uh worst quality i would say is
uh
okay okay okay so obviously probably my
worst quality would be maybe a little
bit selfish
okay so to speak in terms of the fact
that
again it comes to sort of i'm very goal
goal orientated and driven and so
if if something's a little bit
you know gonna detract form from that
from that path
then uh yeah it's in a little bit of
tiny bits open i probably say that
that's probably my worst quality and
it's something i've definitely worked on
um over time knowing that you know
know we need to be less selfish and what
about you what would be your your worst
quality
um i would say
yeah i think what i kind of touched on
before like i'm a really big planner but
sometimes that makes me like a bit
inflexible i i'm trying to live more in
the moment and not like plan everything
out even with like little things like
holidays and stuff like that like i'll
be that person with the itinerary about
what we're doing you're going to give me
the wallpaper
yeah yeah yeah and i'm trying to just
like also just relax more and enjoy and
not everything has to go according to
plan because i feel like i get pretty
upset when things don't go according to
my plan so trying to like let go yeah i
see you i mean you know just to bang a
quote out now the best laid plans you
know from of mice and men they often go
on right
why are you still single
why am i still single
um
i'll probably say
again because obviously
with uh like the last relationship it
kind of ended and so
now after that relationship it i was
very much focused on
my goals
uh and and my like you know my work and
stuff like that why are you still
thinking um yeah kind of a hard one to
answer i would say
i think my last
i've had one serious relationship and it
definitely messed me up a little it took
me quite a bit to like get over that um
because like i said i really thought i
was gonna like end up with that person
um and yeah and i think sometimes for me
i definitely date a lot my friends call
me like a serial dater but i sometimes
have a hard time maybe like connecting
with people because i've moved around a
lot i'm kind of the same like i'm really
passionate and like goal driven about my
career and i don't know i just feel like
i haven't really found someone who
matches my energy in that way um so yeah
see so is it is it like one dating by or
what are we saying like a couple days
how many usually a couple days i'm
always like i'm always down for a second
date unless the first date is like
horrible
would you like to see each other again
okay
do you want to get first
ladies first um yeah sure i would love
to see you again
i really appreciate that um you know me
yeah sure like why not like i think we
had a good good time here we learned a
lot about each other and yeah i thought
it was good yeah somewhere without
cameras would be yeah
sure under the bright lights yeah
thank god you guys said yes yes got to
be the first yes yes today oh really
come on
it was good it was actually really fun
and i feel like we talked about a lot of
really interesting topics what do you
think of those
i thought you know she's she's a
brilliant girl and uh yeah for sure i'd
love to love to get her to know her a
little bit more i know you guys were you
relieved when she said yes
yeah i was i was i was a little bit
relieved because i thought you know
there was a bit of a chemistry there and
it's you know it's always good to have
that in the bank so yeah we'd love that
well i'm very very spiritual oh you like
very strong stuff yeah like my mom she
is
you know a mindfulness instructor she's
like
a healer like she's everything like
within the spiritual field
and so i was obviously brought up
believing everything like ghosts and
whatever i do believe in sorry ghost is
in like um
casper or ghost is in like someone
coming back and yeah like people yeah
being hooked with you well
i was
apparently i've seen things where you're
like you'll be standing at a bar and
then like next minute ghosts having a
pike next to you because they
come back to see you and stuff
you don't believe in that i mean that's
ah